as we told you at the top of the program
President Trump says there is no longer
a nuclear threat from North Korea
he's also defending his decision to halt
US military exercises with South Korea
during negotiations with Kim jong-un's
government all of it is creating as you
can imagine quite a stir on Capitol Hill
correspondent Kevin cork has tonight's
report from the White House after more
than 45 hours on the ground and another
22 in the air President Trump returned
from his historic Singapore summit with
Kim jong-un amid strong headwinds of
skepticism that the summit produced
plenty of declarations by the White
House but far few details but that
didn't stop the president from
unleashing a tweet storm of optimism
declaring the world has taken a big step
back from potential nuclear catastrophe
there's no longer a nuclear threat from
North Korea before adding North Korea
was our biggest and most dangerous
problem no longer sleep well tonight the
president has come under stinging
criticism in some corners because of the
one and a half page statement that he
and Kim Jong unsigned in Singapore
spelled out no specific commitments from
the north aside from working toward the
complete denuclearization of the Korean
Peninsula a promise that the regime has
repeatedly made and broken since the
1990s on Capitol Hill a furious debate
over whether or not the president gave
away far more than he extracted from the
meeting raged on today with members on
both sides of the political spectrum
expressing skepticism this summit was
much more show than substance what the
Texans call all cattle no hat
after all the pomp and circumstance have
faded it seems clear that Chairman Kim
walked away the victor unfortunately
this is the country that made promises
before and is broken and we're not
talking about promises here regarding
you know minor items these are nuclear
weapons and ballistic missiles that have
the capability of reaching the United
States the president should be applauded
first for disrupting the status quo now
let's go get an agreement and we should
be under no delusion this is going to be
fast Secretary of State Mike Pompeo says
he expects North Korea to take major
steps toward nuclear disarmament during
president Trump's first term telling
reporters in Seoul we're hopeful that we
can achieve that in the next two and a
half years before adding there's a lot
of
word left to do that's why the words
verifiable and irreversible we're not in
that document signed by the two leaders
in Singapore Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo said today because the words
complete denuclearization were in the
document that encompasses both right
Kevin Cork live on the North Lawn Kevin
thank you